Cause it's not actually a gas. It's a, quite a thick,
heavy oils developed in the 1950s during some pesticide research actually.
And they found some agents which were particularly toxic.
I believe that nerve agents are some of the most
dreadful chemicals that chemists have ever synthesize.
The V stands for venomous agent.
So this is venomous agent X and there was a venomous agent G and various
other ones. So it was the 22nd, 23rd one,
wherever X is in the alphabet that they are they've made,
or perhaps you just signed it sinister.
Fortunately there is an organization based in the
Hague, the organization for prohibition of chemical weapons,
which over the last 20 or so years has succeeded
in getting 95% of all the stocks of chemical weapons
in the world to be destroyed.
Full here, uh, of the VX agent. It's got a number of atoms,
as you can see,
this is a phosphorus based agent as a lot of these nerve agents are.
So here we have a phosphorous, we've got a double bond to an oxygen.
We've got ethanol group here. The interesting group is this here,
and this is derived from touring.
This is a sulfur and in taurine that has more oxygens on it in this case though,
it doesn't. And this phosphorus,
the sulfur bond here is a very weak bond.
And that is the key part of this molecule,
which reacts when it meets your nervous system.
I think that this chemical is obviously terribly
dangerous even to store because if it gets out that potentially it could
cause enormous damage kill thousands,
or perhaps more people depending how it's distributed.
So these are all called nerve agents, uh,
and that's because they interrupt your nervous system.
So the normal neurotransmitter, which is used in your nervous system,
uh, is this here, this is, uh, acetone Coleen.
So the nerves work by saying electrical signal from your brain to your muscles.
And when they get to the muscles, there's a junction.
The electrical message gets converted into a different type of message.
And you're a transmitter or many,
many thousands of neurotransmitters that are released may drift across the
synaptic gap to the muscle. And they accumulate in receptors.
And the more accumulation is the more of the stimulus for that particular
muscles. So your lungs, for example, constantly being told to breathe in,
breathe out. Your heart is constantly being told to,
to beat and pump blood around you. And when you want to move your hands,
your brain is telling the muscles here to contract or all released
this neurotransmitter, acetylcholine. This is responsible for much of that.
There are other neurotransmitters too, but this is the key one for that process.
So this, when it gets released,
it soaks up into all the receptors, but of course, it's yeah.
Point you want to release your hand or your arm wants to beat the other way.
And so these go in and I have these receptors and then there's another molecule
called acetylcholine Estrace, which just comes along and chomps them up.
Um, I call it the Pac-Man molecule cause he can imagine, yeah,
something coming along and
it literally breaks here, uh,
to make a seasick acid vinegar and coding,
and the colon gets recycled back in the cell and
recreate more of the neurotransmitter. This is going on thousands of years,
times a second. It's a very fast process. So how does the X work? Well,
it works by mimicking this molecule here.
I'll say this molecule is the natural food. If you want for Pac-Man,
this molecule comes in and this again is a very weak bombs.
And so it comes off. Then this gets attached to the Pat marrow molecule.
So the normal process would be that the Syrian refugee would come in and attack
the carbon of the acid tile Coleen
to make this carbon oxygen bond.
And then water can come in and pluck that off again. Yeah.
And that happens many times a second. So this is always around to,
to eat more like a pair of scissors, snipping,
all the acetate groups off when we have the phosphorus talks to him bond,
though, it's on there for good. It's not coming off unless you administer.
So what happens is now that you're asked to tell Coleen in your,
your sign-up tick gap in the nervous in that junction,
if you like between the muscle and the nerve,
that's not being eaten up always there.
So it's always going into the receptors to tell your muscle to contract.
And of course, you know, if it's the heart or if it's yeah, your lungs,
while that's very quickly going to gonna really mess up your normal
breathing, uh, and, and living in D most people, uh,
who have this type of poisoning, um,
they dies is fixation because their lungs have stopped working correctly.
And of course all your peripheral muscles are being told by the same substance
what to do. So you, you will get uncontrolled movement convulsions.
So really not very pleasant at all the other very common one,
which a nerve agent, which people have used, uh,
urge of at least, hopefully not used is sarin.
So VX is actually far more potent than even sarin.
It's extremely potent. So around about 10 milligrams, that's one,
a hundredth of a gram, really not very much,
really very much is enough to kill an average. Yeah.
It has to be admitted that this video is the first
opportunity that I've had of wearing this tie that was
sent to me by a fan anonymously.
I don't know which fan about chemical weapons.
This is not the sort of tie that one can wear at a party.
People are not going to enjoy themselves when they see vomiting, diarrhea,
and the likes written on my tie,
but today it's really quite useful and appropriate.
And I think that fan whoever he or she was for sending it to me.
This initially reacts with the phosphorus,
the sulfur to make this bond here. And then this group migrates down here,
and that happens at a fairly rapid process.
So the idea was to have elemental sulfur,
which is just a nice yellow powder and this other substance QL and within the
actual missile were called binary missiles or binary bombs.
The chemical reaction would occur to make the very nasty nerve agent.
And that of course, made the bomb much easier to assemble.